what are you going to tell
a club president a general manager an
owner when you go and interview say in
early january
about how you're going to be better this
time around well i know how to build a
world championship program and my
awareness
and my instincts will be much sharper
that that's one thing i do know and i
feel very confident about because this
process has given me that
mike mccarthy with peter king you know
mccarthy and i got to give him credit i
got him cause i was skeptical when
mccarthy emerges from hibernation last
month and goes on this media tour that
seemed to be aimed at reminding everyone
that mike mccarthy exists i was under
the impression that maybe the guy's not
getting a whole lot of action behind the
scenes because you don't need to do all
this
if you are on the radar screen of teams
that are looking for vacancies and he
ended up being on chris
every team's radar except washington
they locked on to ron rivera but he was
a candidate for all of the other
vacancies and
next thing you know
and it's fitting right right a
protracted divorce from jason garrett is
followed by a vegas wedding between
jerry jones and mike mccarthy just like
we all saw it coming but
jones realized mccarthy's the guy why
wait let's get it done and yesterday
morning it happened yeah that's right
and i mean
you know it's the perfect fit yeah all
those people all those other teams the
browns the panthers the giants all
interviewed interested in mike mccarthy
this was the spot
that makes the most sense i know we
talked about this last week
we had a conversation about this and i
was kind of pounding the drum for this
too it makes the most sense for the
dallas cowboys yes like he has a little
bit of a
uh somewhat of a black cloud because he
didn't win more than one super bowl you
know with aaron rodgers in green bay but
still to compare his career resume to
jason garrett it's not comparable that
way one i think there was a lot of teams
there that he took to the playoffs that
weren't as talented as some of the
dallas teams we've seen not make the
playoffs the last few years he is a
general he's capable of being the
general of this ship and the one thing
we can always say about the packers they
were tough ships don't have generals
well whatever you know what i mean but
yes all right but they were tough they
were disciplined and they were pretty
good situational football and really you
know to be totally honest about it too
right i mean if one guy catches an
onside kick they've been there they've
gone to two super bowls in green bay and
i don't blame him for that they were
prepared properly they just had a guy
who literally dropped the ball in a big
drop the ball moment
i i think that it is very easy for jerry
jones to convince himself that the
talent level of the cowboys over the
past decade is comparable to the talent
level to packers over the past decade
and there's a lot of ego and pride that
comes into that analysis but is it
really a stretch to say that the cowboys
with tony romo right right right for
most of the decade yes dak prescott
immediately upon the conclusion of tony
romo's career and actually there was one
year of overlap where romo was injured
ezekiel elliott demarco murray before
ezekiel elliott you can make the
argument that the teams are roughly
similar and what's the difference been
dramatically it's been the coaching and
mike mccarthy his resume much better i
mean the guy won the super bowl that's
right jerry's building yeah the year
that jason garrett became the head coach
of the cowboys and he beat garrett twice
in the divisional round that's mike
mccarthy is the reason why it's been 25
years one of the reasons why it's been
25 years since the cowboys have been to
the nfc championship he beat them twice
that's right he did i mean he went into
dallas in 2016 when the cowboys were the
number one team in the nfc one of the
best teams in football and yes you know
al coached them outclassed them whatever
but you know kind of dominated and
controlled the football game as the
lesser team on the field that day uh so
that does say something and listen i'm
probably a big reason of why there's
somewhat of a little bit of a black
cloud around mike mccarthy because i
complained about his offense the last
two three years of his career there with
green bay i thought it was too reliant
on aaron rodgers and the other aspect i
like of this is you know the fact that
he is entertaining kellen moore like to
me that would make a lot of sense mike
mccarthy make plays but you know kellen
moore he did bring some good things to
this dallas cowboys offense this year
too to where i think you know any really
hey smart coaches be they're
collaborative bill belichick has had a
lot of great coaches on his staff he
steals things from them they leave the
door i don't think enough coaches do
that it makes sense uh kelvin moore
there and then of course i like the mike
nolan hiring as the defensive
coordinator too mike because it goes
back to game plan specific stuff
here's another angle
and and as to kellen moore i don't think
mike mccarthy's got a choice i think
that was one of the terms of employment
because i like it a little bit right i
think kellen moore becomes their new
jason garrett the guy they groom to
eventually become the tom landry that
they thought jason garrett would be
right because moore's what 30 31
i mean
you could have mccarthy in this job for
10 years then stephen jones elevates
kellen moore after everything he's
learned from mike mccarthy and it's one
big happy family extending decades into
the future i think kellen moore is the
candidate to be that guy but you know
think of what happened in the latter
years for the packers there was that
sense of complacency those comments from
aaron rodgers that he tries to act like
weren't an attempt by him to send a
message and it clearly was not enough
energy on the sidelines not enough of a
sense of accountability that if you
don't do your job you're not going to
have a job i think that mike mccarthy
will avoid the complacency in dallas
because in dallas he has what he didn't
have in green bay chris an owner in the
building an owner in the building yeah
exactly right right and the owner in the
building is the general manager yeah and
unlike ted thompson who stayed in his
office with the door shut and locked i
don't know that for a fact but as far as
anyone could tell outside the building
that's where he was he never said
anything he never did anything he only
rarely signed free agents you got the
jimmy john uh jerry jones wheeling and
dealing and and he's the gm and he's the
owner and he's out there sucking up all
the attention and mike mccarthy can just
focus on being the coach but he also has
to worry about having an owner around
all the time it's going to keep him from
becoming complacent that's right i mean
yeah you listen to some of the stories
mike mccarthy you know you know
allegedly got a massage in his office
right like none of that's going down
it's not going down in dallas because
the jones family's there they're
prevalent every day they got keys to
your office mike mccarthy don't get any
massages they can bust in at any moment
all right so yes and you know i think it
is it's fair to say i mean that shows to
be a successful model too
you know when the organization is in the
building on a daily basis as compared to
some of the other teams where
ownership is not in the building if you
look at the correlation there yeah
there's a lot more success with those
teams that have the owners there on a
daily basis it's checks and balances it
lights a little fire under the coaches
butts too and the head coach especially
to know oh there's the guy that pays
everybody there's the guy that pays me
in the lunch line oh he's walking around
the hallways talking some coaches i
better get on my game i bet you know so
uh i think that is a very real aspect of
why this would be a good marriage and
and certainly maybe be improved compared
to a green bay with mike mccarthy
yeah and and look
it's never going to be any better than
it is the first day and i the first like
i don't know how to feel about this from
the standpoint of this kind of shotgun
arrangement that happened so quickly and
it really is odd to me that a
multi-billion dollar business would move
so quickly at the most important job
that it can have the head coach of the
football team but jerry jones saw
something heard something i was told it
was basically love at first sight
there's the report that that mike
mccarthy spent the night at jerry jones
house and once that happened everybody
knew it was going to be a done deal it
really is amazing to me that that after
that slow process of separating from
jason garrett it fell together so
quickly with mccarthy and i can't help
but wonder whether or not jason garrett
at some point last week convinced jerry
jones to go interview a few people and
see if he could find somebody better
before he fired jason garrett and it
only took two interviews for jerry jones
to find someone that he liked better
well yeah maybe but i mean it just it
made the most sense i mean again we've
talked about this a lot right i mean
this is where i think we were alone like
no lincoln riley you know none of that i
just don't think this team is ready for
that you don't want a team that's ready
to win right now
basically sitting there going wait we're
waiting for the coach to get used to the
nfl life and things like that oh yeah we
got to wait we we were saying that we
we well you were the one that kept
banging the college coach drum i was
saying that jerry jones had told us
everything we needed to know about
college coaches he said it three weeks
ago we just didn't want to listen i
wasn't banging from yeah
and dan mullen i've banged the drum for
them to hire mike mccarthy so that's the
drum i banged i just basically said i
thought they were going to go the
college coach route and i didn't agree
with that i mean i have never said that
have you you have you been listening or
have you been texting your copy and
pasting yes because that's what i've
said i have you not heard me say they're
ready to win now they're in the super
bowl window i don't know if a college
coach is ready to do that yes okay okay
i'm i'm sorry your analysis was good
your information was bad yes
yes
that's it exactly right thank you at
least you corrected that you jerk all
right uh i bought one last thing on
jason garrett because remember the
report from
november ish that if the cowboys don't
keep him his first choice is to go coach
the giants well no one has shown any
interest in jason garrett as a head
coach the browns have a vacancy the
panthers have a vacancy and the giants
job is still open paul schwartz of the
new york post is now reporting that the
giants will only turn to jason garrett
if things go south with their number one
choice who is matt rule the baylor head
coach and it's been pointing in rules
direction yes from day one so so garrett
now becomes the the fallback option or
one of the fallback options in the event
that rule doesn't get the job i don't
even think they consider garrett
unless and until rule says no or they
can't work it out i just i'd
i'd be stunned chris if jason garrett
lands on his feet as a head coach
somewhere else after after all of the
flaws that we've do you know everything
about i just i don't see it happening if
it does
god speed more power to him but i don't
see it happening no i i can't say that i
see it happening either i think it has
to be one of those where
yeah he'd probably have to go back to
being an oc
rebuild his reputation a little bit that
way there
and then come back to the head coaching
vacancy table at some point to say hey i
got this experience and look at where
i've grown as an offensive play caller
and grown my playbook and things like
that ultimately yes i agree with you
there and you know to your point with
the giants it does seem like all things
all signs point towards matt rule being
the top guy or the lead candidate there
for the new york football giants
i don't think he's got the coaching
self-awareness to do that though
to change change we've seen the
resistance to change the rel you saw in
the the eagles game yeah they went back
to the things that created problems in
the past without the you know i i just
it's almost like he's resisting anything
other than old school line them up our
guys are better than your guys and we'll
tell you what the play is and we're good
enough to beat you that's his style and
i don't see him changing it yeah well if
he wants to be a head coach i think he's
going to have to change it so you're
right i mean that'll be on him to look
into the mirror and kind of uh
self-evaluate thyself as we say and see
if he can make those changes because
yeah you're right i mean after the
giants next year with the teams that
come open you're right just right now
with the stigma around jason garrett i
don't think it's going to excite fan
bases when they hear oh jason garrett
might not be our next head coach the
perception is not uh not as good and
and a little disheartening or at least
not good for jason garrett
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports